so we talked about it again at the
februari meeting and I said look let's
buy the June meeting really figure out
what the plan is and I'll say a couple
things about it um there you know people
sort of scribe you can see in the press
that there are these you know at the at
the Star Chamber meeting after the board
meeting there was all these nefarious
things happen it was just this a
three-hour conversation we had where we
decided look we want to be able to do a
full search for the right next leader
for the company if we try to do that
behind closed doors are in secret heck
the moment you start talking to a couple
candidates it's going to be out there
and then that it's going to just be a
bunch of nonsense and a distraction for
the company so we want to do it out in
the open and we decide if we ought to do
it out if we're going to do it out in
the open we should really think about
bringing jack in as the interim CEO now
which we're doing because again if we
don't do that the public distraction of
when are they going to when is the
person going to be here and you know and
and and dicks walking around like with a
with a timer on his head we just thought
that was going to be ridiculous and I
agreed with that and so we decided you
know is easy you go into that meeting
thinking that that was the possible
outcome we went into the meeting I think
open to having a discussion about what
the timing was going to be there had
been some criticism particularly from
Chris Sacca and early Twitter
shareholder big Twitter shareholder and
it seemed in some ways it wasn't
personal but you know he said the
Twitter hadn't done a great job telling
a story that it could be so much more
did you take any of that personally well
you can't take it you can't take any of
that stuff personally I mean as a CEO
but you better be able to be you know
have have some balance of I told at the
code conference I told kara swisher
think great CEOs are a balance of
resilient and you know they're gritty
and resilient but they're self-aware and
you have to have that combination and
not take these things personally look we
have the blessing of working at a
company that everyone cares about and
thinks about a lot and and it's been
that way since I got to the company in
2009 everything we do is in the
spotlight and people have opinions about
it and they want it to be more like this
or more like that that's a great thing I
mean
much rather work at a company like that
then some place that people don't care
about have heard you say that before but
still I mean Sokka has made let's say
early investors have made hundreds of
millions of dollars yeah via their
twitter shares under your leadership
there has to be something personally
galling about the fact that then he oh
you know look that's all it's already
it's all a rich tapestry